à vous l'avez tente attendue celle là
allait enfin sur trois histoires dollars
aujourd'hui trois histoires avec les
mécaniques différentes comme d'hab et y
en a une d'entre elles particulièrement
la dernière la dernière puisque comme ça
vous regarde et vieux jusqu'au bout et
je suis bien fiancé e horrible georges
me dit ça se trouve ça m'arrivait je
mens sport du coup c'est horrible mais
on commence avec la première qui est
l'histoire de martin contextualisations
martin vit seule dans un appartement au
rez-de-chaussée d'un quartier qui
indique être pas ouf pas très bien
fréquenté appartement au rez-de-chaussée
la fenêtre de sa chambre donné sur une
ruelle et à quelques mètres de la rue il
y avait des poubelles et souvent il y
avait des homeless qui venaient faire
les poubelles
alors ce pas une histoire sur la durée
qui a duré plusieurs semaines ou quoi
danser un one shot ce qui m'angoisse exa
peut vraiment tomber sur la gueule à
tous tout guidé au rez-de-chaussée pas
moi moi je suis tranquille
un matin un peu avant l'aube il fait
encore nuit martin se réveille et il
l'entend toqué à sa fenêtre horrible
horrible situation partie spécifique
quand sa toque à la fenêtre il est deux
à celle ci il n'est pas face à celle ci
et ce détail a son importance pourquoi
parce que les stores de martin était usé
genre y manquer vous savez c'est
l'histoire va exactement comme ça où il
manquait des lattes
quand il manque une latte au genou
sortir de l'ambiance est vendue la dent
gross a fait un écart tu vois quand même
assez considérable ce détail a son
importance puisque martin dit que si
quelqu'un vraiment en toc et à sa
fenêtre ça veut dire qu'il peut voir
martin donc martin agir en conséquence
il est trop malin déjà il est trop malin
s'est amusé il explique que le son a été
bref genre ya eu cinq à six blocs à sa
fenêtre
après avoir passé plusieurs secondes
être paralysé dans son lit et a demandé
ce que c'était que ça il ya de nouveau
des toques et à partir de là martin et
comprend qu'il ya quelqu'un probablement
qu'il regardait dormir à travers sa
fenêtre et qui a décidé on ne sait pas
pourquoi d'un coup de tokai clairement
si c'était un pote à martin ou quelqu'un
de sa famille ou quartz amuse pas à
toquer à la fenêtre c'est nul tu vas
juste ok à la porte d'entrée comme tout
le monde et à ce moment-là mars à un
très bon instinct il se dit il faut pas
que je m'arrete ronde parce que la
personne qui a toqué c'est ce qu'elle
attend de moi que je me retourne et que
je la regardais à partir de l'âge pas ce
qui va se passer donc il ne se retourne
pas il est très malin c'est ouf il va à
la place juste s'asseoir tout doucement
sur son livre toujours dos à la fenêtre
comme s'il venait de se réveiller et
qu'il avait la tête un peu dans le coup
et il va se lever se diriger vers sa
salle de bain qui est donc en dehors de
sa chambre ce qui est totalement
crédible plupart des gens se réveillent
plusieurs fois la nuit pour aller aux
toilettes et du coup il y va il va jouer
ce truc là à partir de là il est hors de
la vue du mec qui à la fenêtre puisqu'il
est hors de la chambre et se précipite
sur son téléphone pour appeler le 911 la
police aux états unis et il fonce vers
sa porte d'entrée pour s'assurer qu'elle
est bien fermée de manière à être sûr
que le gars qui a toqué à la fenêtre ne
puisse pas rentrer dans l'appartement à
partir de là martin il comprend qu'il ya
deux possibilités soit il reste enfermé
dans son appartement et la personne
n'arrive pas à rentrer soit il prend la
fuite dont qu'il sorte son appartement
et étape le sprint de sa vie sauf qu'il
est pas sûr de courir plus vite que son
assaillant
hélas pas le temps de prendre une
décision que la méga badens il entend la
fenêtre de sa chambre
s'ouvrir le mec a réussi à l'ouvrir
c'était mais énorme coup de chance il
entend son voisin du dessus mike qui
descend ses escaliers martin
déverrouille sa porte d'entrée ils
l'ouvrent de quelques centimètres et
demande à mark de venir l'aider qu'un
truc bizarre qui se passe est précise
que mike c'est un bonhomme le mec il est
très grand très large elle avait entendu
dire qu'il avait en plus fait des arts
martiaux etc
donc il est assez en confiance à l'idée
que mike vienne l'aider mike le gars sur
des sens se précipite à l'arrière de
l'appartement au niveau de la fenêtre de
sa chambre qui maintenant la rue est
donc là où il ya le possible intrus et
au bout de quelques secondes il l'entend
un mec se faire plaquer contre un mur et
vers jetés dans des bus bonne nouvelle
c'est pas mikes et l'intrus il y avait
bel et bien un mec avait ouvert la
fenêtre et qu'elle est rentrée dans la
chambre de martin sauf que mike est
intervenu l'a empêché d'entrer dans la
part et plusieurs secondes après tout ce
bordel il ya mike qui revient qui lui
dit t'inquiète pas mec tu vas pas le
revoir de sitôt
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que le mec a
réussi à s'échapper et que c'était pas
du tout une personne sans abri qui
venait dans la ruelle pour checker si
les pas des trucs a récupérés dans les
poubelles ou des trucs à récupérer chez
martin ce qui est bador ça veut dire que
le gars il était pas là pour la survie
il était là dans un autre but en ce bas
lequel mike précise qu'il l'a vu
s'enfuir du coup est monté dans une
voiture de sport pour rouge et prendre
la fuite avec cette voiture l'aprem
martin a foncé vers la police pour leur
expliquer ce qui venait de se passer est
en fait ils ont dit que c'était juste un
gars qui l'avait repéré quelque part et
qu'il avait suivi jusqu'à son domicile
dans le but de on sait pas on peut
imaginer tout ce qu'on veut mais je
trouve quand même que quand un mec te
regarde dormir à ton insu et ensuite toc
et ensuite où la fenêtre et rentre chez
toi par effraction il est pas mes gars
bien attentionné à l'heure actuelle
martin emménagent et il habite plus au
même endroit suite à cette histoire et
il sait toujours pas qui était cette
personne
et qu'est ce qu'elle allait faire avoir
lui faire donc on remercie my on
applaudit tous mac et on espère tous
avoir en maille qui habite au toucher ok
ok voilà mise en bouche avait pas mal à
j'aime pas ce délire de gens qui te
regardent qui te ce talk et qui veut
rentrer chez toi la [ __ ] c'est
horrible deuxième histoire qui est
différente de celle ci à des parents qui
hélas cette vidéo qui ont des enfants ou
des gens qui s'occupent d'enfants en
centre aéré où j'en sais rien vous allez
vraiment vraiment pas des mêmes mois il
sut pas très sensible vraiment à ça ça
me fait mal c'est l'histoire de lucie
mère de deux enfants un fils de 5 ans et
une fille de 5 ans et demi qui décide à
un après midi comme des tattes marrant
partout dans le monde d'aller au parc
avec eux pour qu'ils jouent qui fasse du
toboggan qui s'amusent tout ce qui a pu
normal elle explique qu'elle doit
rejoindre là-bas une amie à elle qui est
venue avec sa fille là on parle pas
d'une petite aire de jeux comme bien
dans plein de parcs partout en france on
parle d'une grosse grosse aire de jeux
avec un gros parking à côté il ya une
forêt bref lucie arrive au parc et elle
retrouve sa copie elle explique qu'en
plus de son ami il ya aussi une autre
maman qu'elle avec ses deux enfants
qu'elle connaît bien et là cette
personne qu'elle connaît pas c'est un
père de famille qu'elle a avec ses deux
enfants une fille de 10 ans et un garçon
de 12 ans mais il n'a pas du tout l'air
bizarre donc moment aucun danger à
signal tout le monde est assis les
mamans discutent entre elles tout le
monde discute voilà c'est bon enfant
c'est cool bonne ambiance ambiance de
famille les enfants s'éloignent un peu
des parents ils commencent à faire leur
vie au milieu des aires de jeux faire du
toboggan et c est le fils de l'uci veut
faire de la balançoire
sauf qu'à cet âge là pour faire de la
balançoire fait deux fautes et quelqu'un
qui te pousse mais son fils bahia
personnes pour en faire des clous et
donc il est seul tout lucie du coup en
tant que maman extraordinaire se lève
pour aller faire la balançoire avec son
fils et là il ya le garçon de 10 ans qui
est donc le fils du mec qu'elle connaît
paquet au parc avec son fils et sa fille
qui vient la voir et qui lui dit mot
pour mot salut est ce que tu veux que je
joue avec lui lui citron c'est un peu
bizarre premier abord étant donné qu'il
a demandé à l est pas directement à son
fils est un peu bizarre mais elle lui
dit vas-y ok vas jouer avec lui amusez
vous bien il joue un ongle fils de l'uci
et il commence à faire de la balançoire
avec lui et lui cire retourne se
rasseoir et tout ce passe bien dans le
meilleur des mondes pour le moment lui
si elle reste un peu étonné de ce qui
vient de se passer parce que elle dit
que le gamin il avait une voix vraiment
plat il souriait papa tout un tas nation
et une fois qu'il a rejoint son fils
pour jouer il lui parlait pas il se
parlait pas du tout mais bon son fils
joue avec lui et passe un bon moment
donc l'uci elle contente
après plusieurs minutes lui si elle
retourne sur le banc donc au milieu des
autres parents et elle entend le petit
garçon de 10 ans parler à son fils donc
ça y est se mettent enfin à parler donc
elle dit bon ben ok c'est peut-être
juste qu'il est timide avec les adultes
le père de cet enfant de 10 ans se
dirige vers sa voiture ce qui le
rapproche de lui si elle lui dit
la trouvais ça trop mignon que son petit
garçon lui ai proposé à elle de jouer
avec son fils est pas directement à son
fils sauf que le mec en face répond que
c'est pas son fils il lui dit c'est pas
du tout mon fils il lui dit même plus il
lui dit qu'il sait pas qui c'est qui a
vingt minutes il est venu le voir et qui
lui a proposé de jouer avec sa fille et
qu'entre temps il les a suivis jusqu'au
par qui et ce gamin lui si instinct
maman comprend qu'il ya un truc qui va
pas et que c'est très bizarre comme
situation elle regarde vers la
balançoire et surprise son fils n'est
plus là et le petit garçon qui
n'appartient à personne non plus c'est
horrible lucie s'lève elle confie sa
fille et à son amie et elle court vers
la balançoire en hurlant le nom de son
fils après avoir pas mal couru elle les
voit au niveau de l'entrée de la forêt
sachant qu elle précise que les armes
donc l'entrée de la forêt sont vraiment
loin de l'ère des jeux son fils se
retourne vers elle commence à essayer de
marcher vers elle hélas le petit garçon
lui attrape le bras et le tire vers la
forêt sauf que lui si elle explique que
son fils il aime pas du tout être
poussés ou attraper ou tirer est que
quand ça lui arrive il se met vraiment
en colère et devient agressif et elle
explique que c'est le seul jour où elle
a été reconnaissante de ça parce qu'en
fait son fils du coup c'est vraiment
énervé et a commencé à lui mettre des
coups de tête a frappé qui le lâchent
lussier est temps maintenant plus ou
moins proche des deux garçons le petit
garçon mystérieux lâche le fils de l'uci
et s'enfuit dans la forêt et lucie pu
enfin atteint son fils elle le prend
dans les bras et pleurer ses morts
est-ce qu'elle a eu la peur de sa vie il
retourne tous les deux à l'heure de jeu
les amis de lucie entre temps ont
compris que c'était passé un truc
bizarre et c est lucide demande du coup
à son fils pourquoi tu l'a suivi
pourquoi il était là bas qu'est ce qui
s'est passé qu'est ce qui t'a dit son
fils lui explique alors que l'autre
petit garçon voulait l'emmener à les
voir ryan ryan c'est une chaîne youtube
pour enfants où en gros ça gosse qui
vous des jouets qui s'appelle ryan toy
review et c'est apparemment la chaîne
youtube préféré du fils de l'uci et il
n'arrête pas d'en parler et du coup
l'autre gamins à utiliser ça pour
attirer le fils de lucie vers la forêt
en lui disant hey je sais où ryan habite
viens on va le voir tous les deux c'est
par la suite moins vu le jeune âge du
coup et la naïveté du fils de lucie bas
il a dit ok et let's go va si on va
pouvoir jouer avec ryan c'est génial et
l'a suivi comme pour la première
histoire ça finit bien mais du coup on
ne sait pas quelles étaient les
intentions de ces gens en fait en
l'occurrence le gamin on sait pas du
tout ce qu'ils voulaient on sait pas du
tout ce qu'il allait faire on sait pas
du tout si c'était juste un gamin
déranger car j -c seul ou s'il était
dans l'emprise d'un réseau de gens qui
kidnappent des enfants et que ce réseau
utilisé ce gamin pour attirer des
enfants vers la forêt vers eux on sait
pas on n'a aucune réponse à ces
questions là bref mystère non élucidées
est je pense un bon gros traumatisme
pour l'uci qui ne laissera
jamais son gosse avec des enfants
qu'elle connaît pas ou qui ont des
parents qu'elle connaît pas quoi bref ça
me moi qui voulait déjà pas son enfant
ça retarde de 10 ans le moment où j'en
aurais je ne veux pas avoir ses
angoisses la de daron j'ai mes angoisses
de jeunes adultes ça suffit ok la
dernière histoire elle est horrible
parce que je m'identifie pas mal à celle
la presse vous allez vous allez vous
prend de vous expliquer alors voici
l'histoire de mélanie mélanie expliqué
après avoir vécu plus de cinq ans dans
son appartement elle s'est mise à
remarquer que les choses n'étaient plus
à leur place chez elle quand elle
rentrait du travail on parle pas
d'objets qu'on bouge et j'enrage pensait
avoir mis le tournevis dans le placard
et il est sur la table de la cuisine on
parle de trucs qui n'ont pas trop de
sens par exemple savez les fameuses étui
à un couteau dans lesquels on met les
couteaux de cuisine qui tranchent
beaucoup parlé couteau était mis dans
l'autre sens et du coup ils bloquaient
il rentrait pas bien dedans meilleur
exemple dans son dressing donc elle a
des fringues suspendu et des fois leur
entrée les fringues était suspendue dans
l'autre sens plein de petits trucs comme
ça mais boutabout en voyant ça il s'est
dit il ya un truc qui cloche qui est pas
normal mais c'est a pas vraiment de
preuve pour appuyer ce que tu dis et ça
pourrait très bien être juste celle qui
est distraite lorsqu'elle remet par
exemple sa robe dans son dressing ou
lorsqu'elle remet son couteau de cuisine
dans l'étui et c'est là où je
m'identifie beaucoup à cette histoire
c'est qu'il ya plein de moments chez soi
on fait des trucs par automatisme
typiquement orange et services dans son
dressing ont fait complètement par
automatisme vu que c'est la centième
fois qu'on le fait ranger un couteau un
endroit apparaît enfin tout ce genre
d'action qu'on fait toute la semaine
tous les jours ont fini par les faire
vraiment automatiquement et du coup tu
te souviens même pas de quand tu l'as
fait mais tu sais que tu l'as fait est
donc là elle se dit bon bah ça se trouve
c'est moi quand j'étais passé en mode
automatique et que j'ai rangé mon truc
je les mets dans le mauvais sens et je
m'en suis pas rendu compte ça peut
arriver et ça m'arrive moi par exemple
tout le temps elle explique qu'après
plusieurs mois de trucs déplacer au
hasard comme ça de petits détails qui
font qu'elle a ce sentiment bizarre et
qu'elle sent pas bien qu'elle devient un
petit peu parano les choses ont arrêté
de bouger d'un coup mais ça c'était deux
semaines avant qu'elle écrive son
histoire entre temps il s'est passé pas
mal de choses à peu vous parlez de
débile ce qu'elle dit mais moi je
comprends un peu quand elle rentrait
chez elle son chat ils violaient tu
vénères un chat c'est vraiment pas con
comme pour lui indiquer qu'un truc
c'était passé et qui était un peu
anormal et ça attire son attention
inhabituelle les jours passent un jour
mélanie elle rentre chez elle elle
trouve une paire de chaussettes par
terre qui ne lui appartient pas précise
que mélanie ne vit pas avec son maître
le lendemain soir son petit ami vient
dormir chez elle et à lui monta paire de
chaussettes en lui disant un rsa est
sûrement à toi tu as dû les oublier la
dernière fois et son petit ami lui dit
non non c'est vraiment pas moi badens à
partir de là mélanie son copain tu
comprennes
il ya possiblement quelqu'un qui a les
clés ou qui a accès à l'appartement
mélanie et qui va chez elle et enfin le
dernier truc qui a été le déclic ou là
ils ont décidé d'agir mélanie son copain
ça s'est produit la veille au soir du
moment elle écrit ce texte est elle
explique qu'elle est allée dîner avec
son copain après dîner ils sont dirigés
vers chez elle pour finir la soirée et
en arrivant devant chez elle elle a mis
sa clé dans sa poche pour la
déverrouiller et surprise la porte
n'était pas verrouillée
ça peut vous paraître anecdotique sauf
que mélanie explique l intox
avec ça et moi je connais des gens qui
ont le même top ou en fait à chaque fois
qu'elle part de chez elle elle
verrouille la porte et elle vérifie 3,4
fois qu'elle a bien verrouillé la porte
de chez elle tous ceux qui connaissent
mais annie savent qu'à la stocke là
puisqu'elle le fait même avec ses amis
genre quand elle va chez un ami et qui
part de chez lui elle vérifie 3,4 fois
qu'elles sont amies a bien fermé la
porte de chez lui à double tour donc
c'est un vrai top vénère et là le fait
qu'elle rentre et que la porte soit pas
fermée à clé elle a tout de suite
compris que quelqu'un était venu pour la
c1 possibles soit on oublie d'y à
quelqu'un qui est venu chez elle elle en
est maintenant persuadé son copain qui
la connaît bien comprend aussi la
situation et qu'on prend lui aussi que
quelqu'un est venu chez sa mère
il se précipite alors tous les deux dans
la maison pour voir si après quelqu'un
qui est encore là pour voir s'il ya pas
d zurich ont bougé de place
hélas son ex mais à vérifier les
ouvertures dont les fenêtres la porte
coulissante tout ça et bingo et une
porte coulissante dans le salon et elle
est ouverte sauf que mélanie ne laisse
jamais cette porte ouverte ça confirme
alors tout ce qu'elle pensait à propos
des objets qui bougent de place chez
elle qu'elle ait pas folle bref
quelqu'un est venu chez elle et elle
veut savoir qui tu que je viens de vous
raconter là le truc de la porte d'entrée
ça s'est passé la veille au moment où
elle écrit ce texte
quoi qu'il en soit elle explique que du
coup elle a commandé des caméras de
sécurité qui avaient un maître chez elle
et que elle hésite à appeler la police
elle demande aux gens des conseils en
fait de lui dire [ __ ] qu'est ce que je
dois faire quoi c'est assez intéressant
parce que poursuit là j'ai beaucoup lu
l'espace commentaires et ya pas mal de
gens qui lui ont dit mais change tout de
suite sa serrure n'hésite pas à fond ça
prend une journée let's go tu vois tu
sera beaucoup plus en sécurité dans ta
tête et en vrai sauf que mélanie elle
est locataire et pour changer sa serrure
elle doit appeler son proprio et du coup
ça amène beaucoup plus de temps qu'une
journée et un commentaire il ya une
réponse vachement intéressante d'une
fille qui explique qu'il lui arrive est
exactement la même chose il ya 16 ans
elle avait un appartement pareil elle
était en location n'était pas
propriétaire et elle remarquer tout
temps qu'elle rentrait chez elle que des
objets avaient bougé elle retrouver des
fringues par terre elle retrouvait son
make up par angers comme elle elle le
ranger est donc cette fille dans le
commentaire explique que l'élément
déclencheur qu'elle a eu sept personnes
à elle sur son bureau range ses papiers
d'une
hier très précises un truc qu'elle fait
depuis des années c'est un toc callas à
l'aide à sentir bien il le fait à kaka
qu'un jour elle est rentrée il y avait
deux papiers n'était pas au bon endroit
et c'est là où elle a vraiment compris
elle s'est dit c'est impossible que ça
vienne de moi ya forcément quelqu'un qui
vient sauf que là on à la suite de
l'histoire parce que c'était à 16 ans la
meuf à installer des caméras de sécurité
chez elle et bingo les jours passés en
fait elle découvre un jour dans les
roches des caméras que c'est la
propriétaire de son appart il vient chez
elle et qui essayait détenus à l office
mac et avec son make up qui utilisent
ces affaires etc
et c'est absolument horrible horrible
elle est donc allée voir la police
avec ces images sauf qu'entre temps la
propriétaire a eu les caméras et donc
est là elle savait qu'elle s'était fait
griller et du coup elle a entamé des
démarches contre cette locataire pour la
faire virer pour pas qu'elle se retrouve
elle dans la mer devant le tribunal
parce que ce qu'elle fait c'est
parfaitement illégal est horrible voilà
ça me fait pas des vassaux maintenant
quand je vais arriver chez moi et qui
est un truc qui sera pas un endroit où
je pense l'avoir mis je me dire attends
mais regarde mais l'a dit ce qui lui
arrive et ça se trouve je l'avais
vraiment pas mis là et je suis en train
de me convaincre que c'est moi qui ai dû
le faire en mode étourdis qui est d'une
batailleur mais ça souffle j'avais
vraiment pas milla est quelqu'un de chez
moi
allez c'est la fin de cette vidéo
trois histoires d'horreur j'espère
qu'elle vous a plu ça faisait un petit
moment jtrouve vraiment chouette ces
histoires là ne soyez pas parano si vous
pensez que vos affaires en bouger quand
vous rentrez chez vous c'est
probablement vous en réalité je les
avais mis un autre endroit et qui est
convaincu d'avoir mis à l'endroit
habituel je vous dis à bientôt j'ai
tâché vous a plu j'espère que j'ai
raconté ça comme il faut j'espère tout
est clair et c'était pas à débattre sur
tout ça dans les commentaires et à
pourquoi pas raconté dès ce qu'il vous
soit arrivée dans le même genre
l'inventaire et profitons de ces vidéos
là pour que l'espace commentaires
deviennent un espace où tout le monde
raconte un peu ses expériences du genre
voilà je vous dis à bientôt voilà boîte
à me rendre humain ou pièces
[Musique]
on